This will be the equivalent of the long procedure we had before
We are checking if the name at position "zero" is equal to D
or the result of name at position zero is equal to N
That produces the same result
and we've introduced the new construct "or"
which gives us the logic "or" of the two operands on its left and right
so just to see how "or" works
we can use "or" like this
So if we have "True" or "False", the value of "True" or "False" is "True"
If we have "False" or "True", that also has the value "True"
"True" or "True" is also "True", but "False" or "False" is "False"
And I'm showing these boolean literals
This could be any expression we want, like we use the name at position zero here
The one important thing that "or" does is different from other operators
It only evaluates what it needs to
So here's an important example
So we could say "True" or "this_is_an_error"
That will also evaluate to "True"
even though if I just look at "this_is_an_error" by itself
that's an undefinable variable
We didn't define the variable "this_is_an_error"
but when we evaluate the "or" expression
because we already found that the first part was "True", we don't get an error
If we try to evaluate instead of "True" or "this_is_an_error"
if we evaluate "False" or "this_is_an_error"
it's necessary to look at the second operand and then we will get an error
So let's try that, we are doing "False" or" this_is_an_error"
we get an error because since the first operand was "False"
to know whether the "or" is "True" or "False", we need to look at the second operand
and that's not defined
This behavior of "or" will turn out to be very useful
We'll see other places where we rely on the second operand not getting evaluated
if the first one is "True"
So to summarize, here's what the "or" construct looks like
So if the first expression evaluates to "True"
then the value of the "or" construct is "True"
and there's no need to evaluate the second expression
and in fact the Python interpreter does not evaluate it
If the value of the first expression is "False"
then the value of the "or" construct is the value of the second expression